this is swype coming up on the show
Angela finds out how tech could improve
your social skills I go crash testing
with a next-generation protective
material and chris has this week's games
review including the third installment
in the Mafia series welcome to this week
we've been thinking about first
impressions we all know they do count
but not everyone finds it easy to relax
and shine and feed themselves especially
when under pressure like in a job
interview so what's that got to do with
tech well this week angela has been
speaking to the developer behind a new
computer system designed to help make
you a better you just relax and be
yourself can computers teach us to be
our best selves why don't you start with
providing some details about your own
professional background a researcher at
the University of Rochester in the u.s.
believes this is the case he's created a
computer system that trains people to
excel in social settings like a job
interview the program has a virtual
business woman who can recognize your
expressions and prompt you with further
questions as you chat via webcam at the
end of the conversation shall give you
feedback about your interpersonal
performance including your body language
and eye contact from the video data we
look for a face and once you find a face
you look at the facial features where
your eyes are located what's happening
in your muscles and based on this
movement we try to predict your
expression that's a what are you smiling
if you are how much are you smiling from
the audio data we try to extract prosody
this is about intonation so how you very
your voice as you speak designed to
assist individuals with social skills
difficulties there are also apps
offering simulated interview
environments and more general ones
teaching you to relate to relax and
reason with others the fear of
interacting with other people is one of
the most commonly reported phobias
according to a report carried out by
anxiety UK
public speaking is something else that
gives many people the jitters but not
everybody agrees that help should be
automated personal development coach Don
a Hubbard is one of them well I think
technology is a great first step in my
experience as a coach I feel there does
come a point however we're helping an
individual to learn new techniques and
new strategies to be able to enter a
trigger situation for real is the best
way forward what if you could practice
public speaking in the privacy of your
own home whether automated assistants
appeals or not it's hoped for those who
try it over time the level of supported
exposure will help someone to feel more
confident Angela Barnes Sky News coming
up Chris grapples with this year's WWE
gain that and more in this week's games
review but first stay with us because
I'll be finding out just how tough is
tough enough with a unique kind of
protective clothing that's coming right
up after a roundup of this week's tech
news Google's announced a new smartphone
pixel which comes in two sizes as being
seen as competition for the likes of
Apple and Samsung the company says it
has the best mobile camera ever made and
that just 15 minutes of charging gives
the phone 7 hours of battery life
Google's also unveiled a virtual reality
headset to work with the new phone and
other Android devices sky which own
skying uses getting well and truly stuck
into virtual reality with the launch of
a dedicated app it's compatible with
Android iPhone and oculus and starts
with 22 VR films and there are more on
the way a kit for e.coli that allows
users to detect the deadly disease
quickly while at a water source has been
developed by Canadian scientists a team
from Toronto's York University created a
hydrogel matrix which is inserted into
water samples the gel changes color
within an hour of contact with infected
water test results can then be instantly
broadcast to local people buy a mobile
app telling them if the water is safe to
drink Global kids app developer taka
Baca has launched a video streaming
service for children it includes curated
content and a DIY recording tool the
company says everything is prescreened
to ensure it's appropriate so parents
don't have to worry
about what their kids are watching and a
robot has been unveiled by car maker
Toyota that could provide companionship
for anyone who's lonely if you don't
mind it squeaky voice sucka Robo mini is
just four inches tall and will go on
sale in japan for 300 pounds we love it
when we get to investigate clever
materials here on swype especially when
they have a purpose for good so when I
heard about a special kind of energy
absorbing material being trialed to help
protect motorcyclists and other sports
people I went straight to the developers
lab at Imperial College London to see it
in action this helmet is about to suffer
a major blow coming at it with a speed
of 6.2 meters per second this is
actually the peak rotational
acceleration what does that mean is that
the spin the sort of whiplash yeah it's
similar to whiplash it's effectively how
much that the head is you know whipping
round from that impact and how badly
injured with the person wearing that
helmet have been so if we look at this
trace the peak of this trace is actually
at about six and a half thousand
kilowatts a second squared and that
would roughly equate to about and eighty
percent chance of confession or an
eighty percent chance of mild traumatic
brain injury and now repeat the test but
this time using a helmet lined with our
Majel an energy absorbing material that
doctor plant and his team have been
developing for the past ten years with
the help of a government grant we look
at the peak here of this helmet so we
get that translates to just below four
and a half thousand actually four
thousand three hundred kilowatts is it
what does that mean for injury to the
rider so this is obviously a large
reduction in the measured rotational
acceleration but that actually equates
to about a twenty percent chance of
concussion or twenty percent chance of
ultimate in brain injury so what is it
about the armidale helmet that's made
the difference so we've been adding
these energy absorbing components and
we've been adding these elements around
the helmet and they help absorb that
energy do these affect the comfort for
the rider to some extent they go between
the comfort line around the helmets and
they help the helmet to actually sit
kind of
top of the head a little bit better does
it cost more than a standard helmet if
you get one lined with armiger there be
a small price increase but we're only
adding quite small elements here what
kind of price increase a couple of
percent ratings are majel's rubbery
looking internal pockets stiffen on
impact dr. plant originally designed the
material for elderly people so it would
protect them if they fell over so have
an armored I'll component in here that
fits over the hip and absorbs the energy
in a in a sideways but this is underwear
right absolutely how easy is it to wash
yeah you can watch this you can wash
thing every day every day that durable
for a year and here you can see a suit
that some of our downhill mountain
bikers where is this quite hot though
and heavy to wear I mean it's very
flexible and breathable so when you wear
it you actually hardly notice it's there
and the team's also been working on
gloves so we've been adding components
here to protect the nettles against
fracture for the LOD dr. plan says the
latest armor gel helmets have been
developed with two top helmet
manufacturers and a due to launch this
year now tie for this week's games
review including plenty of action and
adventure is Chris mafia free takes
place in the late 1960s and you play as
a guy called Lincoln clothes just come
back from Vietnam and it's not really a
game of many subtleties to say the least
is a very violent tale of revenge but
it's actually told quite well via some
pretty good dialogue it sort of reminded
me of LA noir if anyone out there played
that in 2011 darling
I didn't know you was calm I'm just
backing away your leadership but the
amazing facial technology they use the
animations very good in this game and
they've recreated new Bourdeaux in a way
that is visually absolutely stunning and
like I say it's a tale of revenge you go
through block by block of new Bourdeaux
retaking bits from the Mafia and this
brings in some kind of cool new
management element so you have to manage
your gang and it also means you can
bring people in it's incredibly violent
sort of crass in a way but it also
handles things like race relations in
late 1960s America in quite an honest
way and I think it does everything that
you would expect from a mafia game it's
not bad
I'm a huge wrestling fan and as such WWE
2k 17 was something I was really waiting
for to me 2k of kind of nailed the
fundamentals of a wrestling game but
stripped back a lot of the features that
we'd sort of gotten used to in the older
games for 2k took over this year w.e 2k7
things coming in with a hot tag that is
going to write on the AE podcast scale
very highly I think it's bought in a
slower pace of gameplay which to me
means you're actually putting on a rest
image rather than trying to create a
fighting game which wrestling isn't
really it's not it's it's add more of a
dance it's more of a performance and
slowing down the gameplay means you can
put on that sort of a performance to the
crowd and you can get everyone excited
and all that kind of stuff it's really
cool management modes been expanded my
career mode you can cut promos in my
career mode now so you can be talking
down the camera cut promos with people
who doesn't want that now they've
started playing on all these features
that we were missing from before this is
one of the best ever i mean the only
thing that's missing is maybe a history
lesson from how to wrestling's Joe
Graham that would be amazing but you
can't have it all you've got a lot here
in ww k70 Gears of War for is just fun
first and foremost is just a ton of fun
you follow JD phoenix who's the son of
marcus fenix from the previous game the
storm is coming
and my son is walking right into it it's
just a nostalgic trip of fun for me the
story is a little darker if anything as
it goes along and deals of some i think
is awards always dealt with dark themes
but this does go to some very dark
places but sitting with a friend on a
couch playing the main campaign together
was just a ridiculously fun ride for me
we don't stop these things everyone
within a thousand miles dies almost
always been really fun and gears of war
and they kind of innovated and then
iterated on that thing the multipliers
fun not really the main element for me
but I know there's a lot of people out
there was even compared seen around it
and they all play it if you're looking
to play gears of war and you're looking
to have that same feeling you had when
you played gears of war for the first
time in the xbox 360 for me this did
that like it's not the best game you'll
ever play and it's not going to change
your life but neither did the original
Gears of War you can enjoy it play with
someone else that's my advice play it
co-op you'll have a lot of fun well
that's it for this week but don't forget
you can watch any of our swype episodes
on our youtube playlist just type in sky
new swype and you can stay up-to-date
with all the latest tech stories
throughout a week by taking a look at
Sky News on mobile tablet catch up sky
cute and catch up see you again next
week bye-bye
you